[Music]  I've got my driver's license last week  just like we always talked about cause  you're so excited for me to finally  drive up to your house but today I drove  through the suburbs  crying because you weren't around okay  you know  so you have to say it and and this is  why and I don't mean this in an  offensive way at all I but  this is why we need to rethink allowing  women to have driver's license and like  I said I mean that misogynistically just  rethink driver's license and also voting  but not not in a sexist way at all that  is insane I'm not being sexy how many  pedestrians have been flattened like  pancakes by teenage girls driving around  crying because their boyfriends broke up  with them this is a it's too many to  count this is an epidemic nobody talks  about it  maybe the song is meant to raise  awareness of the problem I don't know